hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
tense 2020 science fiction movie from
france called meander make sure to watch
until the end because there will be a
bonus explanation about the movie the
movie starts with a woman lying in the
middle of the road
shortly after she sees a car coming from
a distance
she stands and moves aside in a days
before the car approaches her the car
decides to stop beside her and man
inside offers her a lift on the way they
introduce each other as lisa and adam
they share about their respective lives
where lisa works as a waitress and adam
works as a night watchman
lisa reveals that her daughter had died
and today would have been her 9th
birthday therefore she wants to kill
herself due to depression by lying in
the middle of the road after a while she
turns on the radio and hears the news of
a man who has murdered two people
the report describes that the suspect is
a white man with short hair and has a
cross tattoo on his right hand
at that moment lisa realizes that adam
is the murderer who slams the brakes
throwing lisa against the car dashboard
lisa wakes up in a closed room with
strange lights on the walls and there
seems to be no way out
she is wearing a special suit and has a
strange device attached to her wrist
emanating a yellow light hysterically
she screams for help as she searches for
a way out until one of the doors slides
open revealing a very long and narrow
tunnel with an exit at the end
the door closes behind her as she crawls
into the tunnel the strange device on
her wrist starts to sound an alarm and a
timer briefly flashes showing 11 minutes
counting down
at first all is going well until a
section of the wall in the tunnel
suddenly shifts
inevitably she has to squeeze through an
incredible narrow passage
she comes to a room with colorful lights
on the walls while looking at the
floating platform in the middle when
passing through the platform it turns
out that the platform functions like a
hydraulic machine that can crush
anything against the ceiling with such a
long distance fortunately lisa is still
able to get away with very little time
remaining
she gets frustrated afterwards while the
timer shows five minutes remaining then
she faces another long hallway with
someone lying in the middle
apparently that person is not a human
instead of a corpse that had been burned
to death
obviously lisa has to move the body
slowly so she can pass through the
hallway
unfortunately the body is too fragile so
it is a bit difficult to move the body
after she manages to pass again the
hallway in front of her rapidly closed
by itself
the timer glows red and it shows a
minute remaining which triggers all the
fire tubes in the hallway
even so a section of the wall behind her
opens to provide a place to hide she
quickly scrambles into the space as a
glass barrier closes her in
sure enough the flames pass through the
hallway when the timer runs out
the hallway narrows again after the
incident and the timer returns to 11
minutes
lisa weeps through the narrow passage in
a supine position
luckily she finds a puddle of water in
the middle of the hallway
then she decides to dive into the water
while looking for another surface on the
other side
eventually the place is flooded with
water leaving little room for lisa to
breathe
she tries very hard swimming to the next
room
she carries on with ragged breaths
while she is resting she hears a man's
voice calling out for help
lisa who is very excited has to pass
through an acid pit with only thin
ledges on either side to crawl on
unluckily her knee touches the acid
injuring her badly
at the end she finds herself trapped
behind a barrier
additionally there is a man trapped
behind another barrier in front of her
and an open stretch of tunnel between
them the man speaks like he had lost his
mind his hair is long and he has a beard
indicating that he has been in this
place for a long time
in the middle of the conversation a
section of wall precipitously opens up
in the tunnel between them the fire
tubes begin to line up on the walls and
both of their barriers are lifted at the
same time
they immediately race to the safe space
as the timer starts to count down after
struggling lisa gains the upper hand and
forces the man into the tunnel by
stepping on his hand when the time is up
the glass barrier drops down severing
his arm that is attached to the device
in a flash she sees a cross tattoo on
the man's right hand and realizes that
it is adam who is burned alive as the
flames fill the tunnel
she then passes out
she wakes up in the same place
a strange skull attached to a mechanical
tentacle appears from the ceiling and
heals her wounds
then it attaches itself to a part of
lisa's suit and she experiences a
flashback of adam attacking her with a
knife she is being stabbed and falls
from the car until she sees a strange
light in the sky
back to lisa's life she leaves the safe
place and takes adam's arm with her
she examines it and sees there are three
markings underneath the device attached
to it the markings are a diamond a cross
and a diamond
unexpectedly a spinning blade appears in
front of her forcing her to move
backwards she narrowly escapes into a
tunnel above
a strange creature appears from a
section above her it begins to chase her
and finally she crawls through a narrow
section of the tunnel so the strange
creature cannot fit through
later lisa comes to a section with two
tunnels to choose from
remembering the markings on adam's arm
she chooses to take the left hallway as
she enters the hallway she hears her
daughter's voice named nina lisa
enthusiastically follows the voice into
a bright white room
she sees all images of her life from
herself as a baby looking up at her
father until seeing her daughter falls
to her death from a window all of a
sudden the strange creature appears
above her and descends into the room it
starts chasing her again through the
next tunnel she sees a bright cloudy sky
at the end of the tunnel but there are
razor sharp wires in the middle with no
other choice she is forced to cross the
wires severely injuring herself
fire tubes start appearing from the
walls then a safe space opens up which
the creature decides to roll into a
hopeless lisa closes her eyes while
waiting to die just before the flames
hit surprisingly the floor opens up and
she falls to safety
strangely she wakes up in the same room
where she started in badly injured she
writes the symbols that she had seen
with blood on the wall for someone else
to find after her the strange skull
appears and begins to heal her again
feeling depressed she wants to die as
she wipes the symbols from the wall
unintentionally she notices that she
just needs to partially wipe the symbols
it turns out that the symbol does not
show two diamonds and a cross simply it
is six arrows indicating directions to
take
she impatiently sets out again
this time she easily passes the same
obstacles as before knowing how to
overcome them when she reaches the acid
pit she burns the device at her wrist
and discovers her own set of markings
underneath her markings are two crosses
and a diamond showing her which
directions to take the creature begins
chasing her again as lisa reaches the
split in the tunnel
she throws her removed device down to
one tunnel to lure the creature and
takes the other
she discovers a strange biological door
that leads to a womb like space
she crawls inside and strange creatures
possibly aliens can be seen moving on
the other side of the womb
she leaves the womb by another exit and
enters a similar room where she notices
her device is on the floor and the
creature is trapped in a door ahead of
her
she slowly retrieves the device but it
sets off an alarm which rouses the
creature and it gives chase again
they move back into the hallway lined by
fire tubes lisa manages to escape into
the safe room and the glass barrier
falls down
however this time the flames don't come
and the barrier opens up again
the wall starts pushing her back out
into the tunnel with the creature she
wrestles with it placing her foot on its
head as the wall presses them both into
the main tunnel its head is crushed
against the wall killing it permanently
at the last split in the tunnel lisa
uses the last mark on her wrist which is
pointing towards the right when she
begins entering the right tunnel she
finds her daughter nina playing a ball
at the left side at last she realizes
her daughter is not real and tells nina
that she has to enter another way
nina hugs her and says she is very proud
of her mother then disappears instantly
lisa crawls into the final tunnel and
sees a bright cloudy sky at the exit
she happily crawls in but there are
three blades falling at faster intervals
initially she is able to get past the
first two falling blades nevertheless
the last blade is falling every two
seconds which seems impossible for her
to pass nothing to lose she forces
herself to pass and almost makes it but
her foot is severed in half by the last
blade
she crawls in despair to the exit with
loss of blood and finds it is merely a
screen with a video of the sky
she starts crying as the fire tubes line
up on the wall
gradually a miracle happens as the
ceiling opens up and she floats upwards
into a bright light she wakes up outside
on a rock in a very beautiful place
her body is fully healed and nina
appears before her
nita says that lisa's body has died many
times but now she is safe and tells her
to stay alive endlessly showing that
supposedly they are in heaven
lisa and nina were victims of adam's
murder the white light that lisa met in
the flashback scene was the light scene
when someone dies assuming it's an angel
however she was taken to the afterlife
first and met adam the maze timers and
strange creature represent the various
tests that she must pass before she can
go to a better place
if you're observant enough the strange
creature is adam who was reanimated
somehow
it can be seen in some scenes that the
creature only has one hand
adam who is a bad person in his lifetime
is trapped forever in the maze
while lisa who always survives death
shows that during her life she was a
good person
the womb that lisa found earlier
represents the process of rebirth
in conclusion she had to leave
everything that makes her as a human so
she's able to live in the afterlife
for example she forgot the concept of
time because it's irrelevant at the end
of the movie
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching
[Music]